[Musique]
bonjour je suis sabine tyrrell je suis
écrivain scénariste de bd peintre
ancienne conseillère principale
d'éducation et présidente de l'udar
nombre aussi de l'académie de l'île de
la réunion
[Musique]
j'aime mes expliqué j'aime le contact
avec les autres et comme je suis
curieuse j'apprends toujours des tas de
choses
et une fois que je peux je sais j'ai
envie de partager avec d'autres
personnes je suis passionné d'histoire
de patrimoine de tout ce qui touche à la
réunion de son
nos origines et à l'instant de venir
puisqu'ils engagé disons culturellement
et moi je j'approche chez un jeu je lis
je fouille donc je partage donc de par
mes tableaux de la peinture c'est une
passion déjà c'est aussi ces suisses et
nostalgique c'est pas la réunion
d'aujourd'hui c'est la réunion qui a été
et qui devrait rester encore un peu
comme ça on a besoin de ça pour exister
et savoir d'où on vient pour pouvoir
justement aller où on veut aller
j'ai eu envie d'écrire un livre sur l'
esclavage j'ai écrit noir café j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait aussi
l'engagisme indiens sont donc j'ai écrit
un livre sur les engagés indiens
jaillard langage et indiennes et la
dernière bande dessinée que j'ai écrite
c'est le moose de la méduse et c'est
pareil
un livre qui parle de la colonisation
que je touche tous les publics
c'est ça l'important c'est qu'on
apprenne sans apprendre comme maintenant
je suis présidente de l'udar de milan
delà des artistes de la réunion et on
essaye tous les ans de faire une action
patrimoniale au east ou historiques
que le patrimoine soit partagée qui soit
abordable et qui soit pas réservé que
pendant les journées du patrimoine
le patrimoine c'est aussi des visites
dans les musées c'est aussi comme ça
pour rendre ou non le dérapage mais
pourquoi n'ouvre pas les musées
gratuitement aux gens